MALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm delighted to host
Professor David Gelernter today
at Google for a talk
on his latest book,
"The Tides of Mind-- Uncovering
the Spectrum of Consciousness."
David Hillel
Gelernter is a writer
and a professor of computer
science at Yale University.
He's a former national fellow
at the American Enterprise
Institute and a senior fellow
in Jewish thought at the Shalem
center and sat on the National
Endowments of the Arts.
He publishes
widely, and his work
has appeared in the "Wall Street
Journal," the "New York Post,"
the "LA Times," the "Weekly
Standard," and elsewhere.
He is known for his
contributions to parallel
computation and for books
on topics including computed
worlds, mirror worlds, and
what he sees as the destructive
influence of liberal
academia on American society,
expressed in his book
"America-Lite00 How Imperial
Academia Dismantled
Our Culture."
In 1993, he was sent a
mail bomb by Ted Kaczynski,
the Unabomber, which
he miraculously
and thankfully survived.
His latest book,
"The Tides of Mind,"
is a fascinating look at the
spectrum of consciousness--
dreams, memory, and creativity.
I'm looking forward
to hearing him
speak for approximately
35 minutes,
and then we'll open
the floor to questions.
And I'm eager to
hear your questions
on for Professor Gelertner.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID GELERNTER: I have to
apologize to Jason and to you
for that antique biography,
which I think I haven't updated
in 1,000 years.
I'm going to have to-- I don't
know where it is, exactly,
because-- I can't update
it because I can't find it.
Anyway, it's very
nice to be here.
It's a pleasure to be here.
It's been a while since
I've been in Cambridge,
and it's always nice to be here.
I've talked about this work
before, the work discussed
in this particular
book, once or twice.
I do have a decent
talk on the topic.
But last night, I decided
to rewrite the whole thing.
Not last night.
The night before last.
Last night, we were
already in Boston.
My wife notified me that
this was a bad idea.
But some people are
ridiculously stubborn.
There's nothing I
can do with her.
So here's the new
talk, and I have
to apologize for its being
not completely debugged.
But I'll give it
my very best shot.
And if I get jammed or stuck
in a loop or something,
just give me a shove.
AI, artificial intelligence,
is a strange field,
very strange-- full of
brilliant achievements,
of course, world class thinkers,
and fundamentally wrong,
it seems to me, on
an important point.
AI's achievements
are well-known.
I think its big mistake
is less well-known,
so I'll focus on that.
But not in the usual, negative
way, certainly not entirely.
For me, this big mistake
is an opportunity,
a fascinating entryway into a
lot of interesting and useful
ideas.
I'd like to discuss some obvious
and important hints that I
think we missed and
we should act on,
and some missed opportunities.
The big mistake I'm referring
to is obviously not universal.
There are a million
different views
in the field, all sorts of
views on basic questions,
in this field and in the
adjacent fields, of course,
we mix with all the time.
But there is a reason the basic
mistake attracts my attention.
And that's because
of the many classes,
courses at Yale and at
colleges across the country--
and I'm tempted to
say across the world--
in which this view is stated
as simple, settled truth.
In science today,
we're just starting
to develop the nasty
idea that there's
only one legitimate side
to contested issues,
and anyone who
disagrees must be crazy.
The ones who suffer the most,
of course, are the students.
They tend to believe us
till they learn better.
AI's achievements are important,
and we all know all about them.
Some company called
Google-- [INAUDIBLE]
might have heard of
these guys-- built
a program that just
beat the world's go
champion a few weeks ago.
Of course, go
resembles chess, is
said to be deeper and
even harder and more
complicated to play.
And significantly, it's
resisted AI researchers longer.
I saw on the news
yesterday, the day
before yesterday
that the defeated go
champion is demanding a rematch,
probably get beat again.
But in any case, mastering go
fits well into AI's ambitions.
Ultimately, AI is
set on creating
an actual human intelligence,
humanlike intelligence,
a humanlike mind.
And that will, of
course, lead inevitably
to superhuman minds and
super-superhuman minds
with gigantic IQ's and gigantic
intellectual capacities,
an issue that I
don't think we've
thought about sufficiently.
In any case, AI
continues to prove
itself an ever more
powerful set of techniques
for building the world's most
sophisticated applications.
It's clear that AI and
state-of-the-art programming
will increasingly grow together
and become a single field.
But I'd like to look
at this basic mistake,
alleged mistake I mentioned,
mainstream AI's mistake,
according to me-- confusing
a sonnet with a grapefruit,
so to speak, confusing a pure
idea or abstraction on the one
hand with a physical
object on the other.
It's attractive to
think of the mind
as a mere well-structured
idea, independent of the way
it happens to be realized in the
human brain, capable of being
realized in
arbitrarily many ways,
as we've heard so
many people say
and seen so many people
write, including, not
incidentally, by software
on a digital computer.
But we have no basis for
arguing that this is true,
that the mind is independent
of its realization.
We'd merely like it to be true.
There is only one known way
to get a humanlike mind,
and that's to
start with a human.
Of course, there
might be other ways,
but we haven't found any yet,
and we have no logical reason
to believe that there are any.
It's an empirical question.
Maybe yes, maybe no.
All we can do is wait and see.
At any rate, the mind is
not a structured idea.
It's a grapefruit
and not a sonnet.
It's a physical thing-- or,
more precisely, one aspect
of a physical thing.
Human mind, one aspect
of the human brain,
or, again more precisely,
one aspect of the human
being-- the human body,
the brain included.
The fact that the mind is one
aspect of a physical-- in fact,
an organic, living
thing-- makes it
natural to see what too many
AI researchers have ignored--
the organic, body-centered
side of the mind
or aspect of the mind.
This physical
quasi-organic view makes
it natural to see the
mind as a tidal object
that changes over the
course of everyday,
changes as gently and
naturally as a flower opening
its petals in sunlight
and closing in darkness.
But the mind's changes
are more complicated
than that, although, I will
argue, no less obvious.
A pendulum that doesn't
move doesn't convey
the reality of pendulums.
If your view of a pendulum
is as an unmoving object,
you're missing
something important.
And constant and gradual change
is basic to the mind, too.
If we don't see
it-- if we don't see
the gentle swing of the
pendulum or the tidal motions
of the mind-- we're
looking at a stopped clock,
taking it for a real clock.
We're missing
something important.
I'll argue that we can't
understand the mind properly
unless we see it as
a changing thing that
follows a predictable
course over the day.
But AI doesn't generally
take this view,
and neither do the fields
adjacent-- psychology,
neurobiology,
philosophy of mind.
Before I look at
that changing mind,
just a final glance
at the sonnet
versus grapefruit debate
and this alleged mistake.
Some people-- a minority,
but a formidable one--
agree with my view.
Or rather, I agree
with their view.
Said in effect, the same
thing about the mind being
a physical object
[INAUDIBLE], Thomas Nagel
being the most prominent among
them, although their goals are
different from mine.
But notice that if I think of
the mind as an idea instead
of a physical object, it's easy
and natural to make the mistake
of seeing the mind as static.
After all, an idea doesn't
change unless we change it.
A sonnet or a
theorem in geometry
or Beethoven's first symphony
is an unchanging, static reality
in ordinary conditions.
If I think of the
mind as an idea
or an abstraction instead
of an organic object,
it's also natural to
think that the mind is
a rationality engine, an
informal reasoning machine.
Many scientists-- I would
argue most scientists
and philosophers-- who
work on this question
identify human thought
with rationality,
with reasoning or
informal logic.
This approach leaves out
a lot of important things.
In fact, it leaves out almost
all of human psychology.
Some mistakes associated with
the mind as abstraction idea
are mistakes any child can
see, which is not a good sign.
The press has been full
of declarations recently--
I don't know why
recently, especially.
But just the weekend
before last, I
saw this again-- declarations
of billionaires and futurists
and just ad hoc loudmouths who
tell us they plan to, quote,
"upload their minds in
digital form to the internet,
and thereby make
themselves immortal."
Two weeks ago or
whenever it was,
quite recently, there
was a Russian businessman
or wealthy businessman who
was making a statement.
This plan will not work.
It might work metaphorically,
but the enthusiasts never
seem to be speaking
metaphorically.
Thomas Jefferson made
himself immortal, of course,
by writing the Declaration
of Independence
and doing a bunch of
other fascinating things.
But nonetheless,
he's still dead.
Abstractions of
Jefferson, summaries
of some aspect of his mind
or some aspect of his work,
can be immortal-- abstracts
of his physical appearance.
We have statues.
We have paintings.
We have engravings--
that can last forever.
They can be immortal.
But Jefferson himself
was a human being,
a particular physical object
that no longer exists.
Jefferson's mind,
being one aspect
of this no longer
extant physical object,
no longer exists, either.
No matter how fervently
AI mainstream researchers
insist that the mind is an
abstraction, nonetheless,
when a human being
dies, he no longer cares
about how many
abstractions of his mind
are kicking around the internet,
no longer cares about anything.
You can tell him he's
immortal, but he's not
going to be interested.
There are strong
positive advantages
to be got, on the other hand,
from seeing the mind as one
aspect of a physical thing.
The mind is a tidal
object, I want to argue,
with its own natural rhythms.
If we miss those rhythms, we're
missing its basic character.
Everyone understands that waking
on the one hand and asleep
and dreaming on the other
are two very different states
of mind, two different mental
states, or two different states
of consciousness.
But the system has more
than just these two states.
The mind moves continually along
a spectrum of different states,
where the waking,
energetic mind is
near the top of the spectrum,
and the sleeping and dreaming
mind is near the bottom.
It seems to me that
we need to understand
how the top and the
bottom differ exactly
and what happens in between.
Consider dreaming, to go
straight towards the bottom.
We experience dreams, but
we don't think about them
much as they unfold.
This simple statement
includes a lot of information.
We experience dreams
emotionally, of course.
We feel them as they happen.
Sometimes, their emotional
color lingers after we've
forgotten all the rest.
Often, they leave us vaguely
uneasy, vague dysphoria
an emotion often
associated with dreams.
But they can also cause
elation or terror.
The most powerful emotions
we know occur in dreams.
On the other hand, we don't
think about them much.
We experience them.
We don't think about
them much as they unfold.
All sorts of improbabilities
and absurdities
happen in dreams, of
course, and we don't mind.
Thinking about and experience--
thinking about on the one hand,
experience on the
other-- are good ways
to identify the endpoints of
this spectrum of consciousness,
the spectrum of
conscious states.
The spectrum's top
edge is thinking about,
pondering the morning
news or the daffodils
outside your window or the
future of American Colleges.
These are intentional states,
in philosophical terms.
They refer to something
outside themselves.
They refer to the news or
the daffodils or whatever,
the colleges.
The opposite pole, the
bottom of the spectrum,
is pure experience, meaning
sensation or emotion.
Feeling is a word
that well captures
this idea of experience.
It's a combination of several
philosophical entities.
Pure being or feeling, sensation
or emotion, is about nothing.
A chill or warmth, seeing
violet, or smelling cut grass,
uneasiness or thirst or
unhappiness or euphoria
must each have a cause.
But they're not about
anything, anymore
than the pleasant
coolness of your forearm
is about the spring breeze.
When the mind moves
over the course of a day
from a state of thinking
about-- up spectrum--
to a state of being or
experience-- down spectrum--
it's moving from one
kind of mental state
to a very different
kind, or mental apples
to mental oranges.
We rarely reach the absolute
top or the absolute bottom
of the spectrum.
But we move from near the
top to near the bottom.
Dreaming itself is
not pure experience
but is a state of consciousness
in which experience tends
to dominate thinking about.
Again, we experience dreams, but
we don't think about them much.
If dreams were pure being,
we'd witness the dream--
see and hear it--
but not take it
in because we wouldn't be
thinking about it at all.
We'd simply
experience the events
as they unfold without
thinking about them.
A sufficiently dramatic
roller coaster ride
might scare you into an actual
state of pure experience,
where you're not
thinking at all.
You're only having
an experience.
Dreams can be close to this
roller coaster state of mind--
not in the up and down sense,
but in the strong emotions
sense.
One symptom of that state
afterwards, evidence for what
happened, is poor memory, such
as our poor memory for dreams.
Having experienced something,
we have to think about it
in order to fix the
short-term memory,
in order to fix the fleeting
impression in such a way
that it can survive
over the longer term.
If we're not thinking about
much, we won't remember much.
And that's the case for dreaming
and for significant parts
of the lower spectrum.
We can only reproduce
the spectrum in software
if we can reproduce the
endpoints, to start.
Thinking about, I believe, can
be simulated on a computer,
and there's been a
lot of work on that.
But no computer can
ever feel anything,
will ever feel anything.
Feeling is uncomputable.
Feeling and consciousness can
only happen, as far as we know,
to organic, Earth-type
animals, and can't ever
be produced-- no matter
what, no matter where we go
and what we find--
can't ever be produced
by mere software on a computer.
But that doesn't limit AI.
Software, of course,
could simulate feeling.
A robot could tell
you it's depressed
and act depressed,
although it feels nothing.
AI in principle could
build a simulated mind
that reproduced all the
nuances of human thought
and dealt with the world in
a thoroughly humanlike way
despite being unconscious.
After all, your best
friend might be a zombie.
Or they might all be zombies.
And would it matter?
Of course, but only to him.
When we say that
we feel some way,
we're saying that our minds
are part of a physical system
and register the state of that
system in the form of feelings.
Consciousness is a property
of a certain kind of object,
just as bounciness
is or rustiness.
You can't download software to
make your smartphone conscious
any more than you can download
software to make it bounce
or to make it rust or to
make it smell like roses.
Those attributes are the
result of physical processes
in a certain type of object.
Why don't we say the
same of thinking about?
I'm saying that the bottom of
the spectrum we experienced
will not exist on a computer.
We could make that
claim in principle
about thinking about, also,
about intentional thought.
It's a deep topic, and
could go on at length.
But we might say just in
passing that the substance
of our thoughts, what
we're thinking about,
can, on the whole, be
described, in English,
some other language,
or maybe a language
in the sense in which
mathematics is a language
or music or drawing.
You know, you have language
in a very broad and metaphoric
sense.
The substance of our
thoughts can be abstracted.
It can be captured
and communicated,
can therefore, perhaps,
be accurately reproduced
outside the human body,
can live and exist
outside the body-- in
vitro, so to speak.
Language is our tool of
abstraction separating
the message from the medium
because language allows
us to separate the
substance of thinking
from the medium
in which we think.
Seems reasonable the thinking
might be accomplished
by using some different medium.
And thinking about
doesn't depend
on the particular platform,
the particular medium.
But feeling can't be
abstracted in this sense.
Feelings can't be
described in language.
Happy or thirsty or
angry feel a certain way,
but we can't put that
feeling into words.
We tend to communicate emotion
not by language, but by using
our bodies, by tone
of voice, gestures,
our way of holding
ourselves and speaking
and so forth, the goal being
to allow the other person
to recognize which
of his own emotions
corresponds to what
we're describing.
And we can do that by
showing him physical gestures
that he associates with
particular feelings of his own.
The sound of middle C
or the look of sky blue
or the feeling of
happiness are famously
impossible to describe.
Basic feelings are primitives
of mind experience.
We can't abstract them
from the medium of feeling,
from the body itself.
And we have no good
reason to believe
that they occur in
any other medium
than the ordinary,
organic animal body.
Returning to the spectrum,
no artificial mind
will ever be humanlike unless
it imitates not just feeling
on the one hand and
thinking about on the other,
but the entire spectrum.
Consider how your mind changes
as you slide down spectrum.
The human mind is a whole
range of shades, not just
rationality.
We begin with something
like rationality,
and gently and gradually
mix feeling or experience
into it, creating a
whole range of shades.
The range is infinite,
but the formula
for creating this
infinity is simple.
At the start of the day, we
tend to be mentally energetic.
We tend to be near
the spectrum's top.
At the day's other end, we're at
the other end of the spectrum.
When we grow sleepy,
we're down spectrum
and moving steadily lower.
During the day, we generally go
through two main oscillations--
drifting downwards towards
a temporary low point.
This is often in the
middle or late afternoon.
Then drifting higher
for a few hours,
and finally downward
again, straight into sleep.
Obviously, everyone
has his own pattern,
but our general course over
a day, our general course,
is from up spectrum to down.
Software could imitate this
spectrum and will have to,
to achieve humanlike thought.
Many mental changes-- changes in
the quality of consciousness--
are associated with this
movement across the spectrum.
When we dream, our
focus is almost entirely
on the inner world, the
inner world of the mind.
When we're wide awake
and mentally energetic,
we focus mainly outside,
on objective reality.
If attention focuses on
the outer world at the top
and on the inner world or
the inner mind at the bottom,
we assume there must be
intermediate states in which it
focuses partly outside
and partly inside.
And, of course, we find
all sorts of such states,
as when we are
daydreaming, for example,
or occupied with whatever
our minds have cooked up
and need to be roused
by people around us
if they want our attention.
But, of course, it's somewhat
easier to rouse a daydreamer
and less dramatic for
the person himself than
to rouse a sleeper.
At the spectrum's top,
we concentrate readily,
and memory, a crucial element
in the picture-- memory
is docile at the
top of the spectrum.
And it supplies facts
and figures and methods
without distracting us
with fascinating anecdotes
and recollections.
Emotion tends to lie low.
It's never completely absent.
Emotion is never
completely absent.
We need it to introduce
value into the world,
to allow us to choose among
different mental directions.
But up spectrum, emotion is
also docile, under control.
It doesn't tend to overwhelm us.
Early mornings are rarely
the time for histrionics
and emotional scenes.
Those come later.
As we move down spectrum,
we lose concentration
and reasoning power.
We come gradually to
rely more on remembering
than on reasoning-- on
the wisdom of experience,
you might call it,
to solve problems,
to react to the world.
Lower still on the spectrum,
the mind starts to wander.
We daydream.
Our memories and fantasies
and ideas generally
are growing vivid and
distracting as the mind's focus
moves from outside to inside.
Eventually, we grow sleepy.
We find ourselves
free associating.
Memory now controls
the mental agenda.
It's no longer docile.
It's no longer under control.
And we pass through this strange
state of sleep onset thought,
or sleep onset mentation, on
the way to sleep and dreaming,
where sleep onset
thought is usually
a series of vivid static
memories or ideas, sometimes--
often-- hallucinatory,
like dreams themselves.
Emotion grows more prominent
as we move downward.
Daydreams and fantasies
often move us emotionally.
Dry, emotionless
daydreams are rare.
And we take it for granted
that we feel our dreams,
often as mere
worrisome uneasiness,
but sometimes acutely.
Up-spectrum thought uses memory
like a faithful, colorless
assistant.
Down spectrum,
memory increasingly
goes off on its own.
The flow of
information from memory
gradually supplants the
flow from outer reality
as we sink into ourselves like
a flame sinking into a candle.
The spectrum suggests
that dreaming
is no strange intrusion
into ordinary thought.
It is the natural
outcome of descending
the spectrum, like
rolling down the runway
is the natural
conclusion of landing
an airplane, landing
in an airplane.
Because our focus shifts
gradually from outside the self
to inside, it's natural
that when we reach dreaming,
it should be wholly
inside, or almost wholly.
Because the role
of memory shifts
from a well-behaved conveyor
of facts and figures
to a supplier of increasingly
vivid and attention-demanding
recollections and
ideas, it's natural
that in dreams,
memory should be so
vivid they seem like reality.
After all, the
memories are becoming
more and more colorful, more and
more attention-demanding, more
and more vivid as we
drift down spectrum.
And it's natural
that in the end,
we find ourselves hallucinating.
Hallucinations are the
most vivid, after all,
of memories or ideas.
Recalling an apple tree in
the fall with brilliant maple
leaves all over and
apples hanging on the tree
can be a vivid memory.
But hallucinating that same
tree is even more vivid.
So dreaming seems like the
natural endpoint of the process
of descending the spectrum.
We need to understand
this whole transition
to understand the mind.
And obviously, there's a lot
more to be said about it.
But does AI need to
reproduce it all finally
to achieve humanlike
intelligence?
I will argue, or
have argued, that it
needs to reproduce
every bit of it,
the entire spectrum,
top to bottom.
One important down-spectrum
activity, for example,
is creativity.
Reporters of personal
experience tend
to suggest that creativity
happens when they are not
thinking hard about a problem,
when they're thinking about it
in the back of one's mind
is a phrase we often see,
when mental focus is diffuse.
In other words, when
they're down spectrum.
Creativity often centers on
inventing new analogies, which
allow us to see an old
problem in the light
of a new comparison.
But where does the
analogy itself come from
is the interesting question.
[INAUDIBLE] for example,
compares the flight
of a small bird
across the evening sky
to a crack in a smooth porcelain
cup, a very evocative line.
But how did he
come up with that?
Certainly not the first thing
you think of in this context.
How did he invent the analogy?
Possibly by using the fact that
these very different things
made him feel the same way.
Emotion is a hugely powerful
and personal encoding
and summarizing
function that can sum up
a whole complex scene in
just one subtle feeling.
Using that feeling
as an index value,
we can search out among huge
collections of candidates
the odd candidate with a deep
resemblance to the thing we
have in mind at the moment.
I think that understanding
emotion as an encoding
and simulating function is
one of the most important
unsolved problems-- in fact,
ignored problems-- in AI
today, ignored problems and
missed opportunities in AI
today-- I would say
in computing today.
In conclusion, once AI has
decided to notice and accept
this, spectrum this basic
fact about the mind--
namely that the pendulum
swings, that mind
is one aspect of an organic,
living, changing, physical
thing-- we'll be able to
reproduce it in software.
We could be working on that
right now, this afternoon
and this morning.
The path from the spectrum to
genuine artificial intelligence
is no short hop.
It's more like a
flight to the moon.
But once we had, in the
past, rocket engines, radios,
computers, and a bunch of
other technologies in hand,
the moon flight--
although it took
genius and daring and tremendous
effort and labor-- was
inevitable.
The spectrum is just one
among the technologies
that's necessary to make
true artificial intelligence.
But it's one that
has been missing.
Of course, once
we've got true AI,
we've got the most dangerous
technology mankind will ever
have developed.
The sooner we start thinking
about that, the better.
But for now, one problem at
a time, and I'll stop there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Are there questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
It seems like your-- the
difference between human
and humanlike is not
something you seem
to be caring too much about.
And one of the things
that you do care about
is having a physical
representation, and essentially
the ability to feel, to
experience, the world.
When you started the
talk, you started
with talking about,
like, AlphaGo
as a form of the mental
model of AI as it exists now.
If the mental model
or the example
was instead the
self-driving car,
then it has a physical
manifestation.
It is all about
experiencing the world.
The key of its intelligence
is seeing every little dog
or pedestrian or anything
that's happening in the world.
And you could even
abstractly say
that it has a state of its
mind that you could call pain
when it intersects with a bus.
You know?
So isn't that the right
model to compare against?
How is that different?
And obviously, it's
not a human mind.
But what is the bar for
starting to be more humanlike?
DAVID GELERNTER: It's
an important issue.
And AI loves to say
things like this.
You could call it pain.
You could also call it
whimsical nostalgia.
You'd have no
reason to do either one.
But this is the crucial
issue between what's human
and what's humanlike--
what's humanlike is
purely an objective issue.
What's human is a
subjective one, also.
What's human has to do
with the state of mind
that we experience.
I don't have any
reason whatsoever
to think that a self-driving
car has any experiences.
Of course, it has sensory input.
I have no reason to think that a
self-driving car sees anything.
Of course it has sensory input,
and it deals algorithmically
and using a variety of
techniques and heuristics
from this input.
But we know that we human
beings, when we see red,
have a different experience
from when we see blue.
In fact, we have an
idiom "seeing red."
colors matter a lot.
They matter more to some
people than to others.
But we have experiences.
It's not just a matter of noting
that the frequency of the light
associated with
this painted wall
is probably X as opposed
to the rug, which
is Y. It feels different.
We have favorite colors.
When pain happens, we don't
say to ourselves, well,
I could call that pain.
We're in no doubt.
It's a kind of experience.
It's a character of experience.
It's a particular,
qualitative experience.
Philosophy of mind uses the word
qualia, of course, to describe,
although in a rather confused
way, to describe feeling.
So it is-- driverless cars
are major achievements of AI
and are technically exciting
in many ways, in some ways.
But they don't move
the ball a millimeter
in terms of humanness as
opposed to humanlikeness.
Is it useful to have
humanlike things?
Absolutely.
It's the only thing
AI can aspire to.
It will never achieve
an inner world.
It will never build a
subjective inner world using
digital computers and software.
But does that matter?
Only to the car itself.
And that's not the issue.
So I completely agree that
we have sophisticated ways
for dealing not only with formal
theorems of the sort whose
proof got AI going.
But you're dealing
with data of all sorts
and dealing with
enormous databases
and dealing with sensory
input and dealing with motion
and dealing with
all sorts of things.
We're making an enormous
amount of progress.
We're lacking something
crucial, which
is the big picture, the
way these things-- the way
the intentional states relate
to the emotional states
or the feeling states.
We're lacking a clear view of
creativity and how it works.
But it's not fair to say "and
we are lacking inner experience"
because inner
experience is neither
a necessity nor a possibility,
whereas objective performance
is achievable and important.
AUDIENCE: So your
idea of the spectrum
reminds me of sort
of current writing
and behavioral
economics, psychologists
like Daniel Kahneman, "Thinking
Fast and Slow," getting away
from the classic, purely
rational homo economicus
trying to describe people
behaving and thinking
as they really do.
How would you relate
your work to that?
DAVID GELERNTER: I think
the work is fascinating,
and there is-- it used to be
said, as a matter of course,
that there are
overlaps between AI
and psychology,
cognitive psychology.
In the past, it seemed to
me that cognitive psychology
had been axiomatically
fixed on foundations
that were not useful.
The first thing that I read in
cognitive psychology textbooks
and heard from cognitive
psychology teachers
was the ground analogy,
that the mind relates
to the brain the way software
relates to a computer, which
is not only false but is
tremendously destructive,
it seems to me, to our
thought in this field.
Psychology in recent
years seems to me
to be doing a lot of things that
are much more interesting, that
are much truer, that are
much truer to human reality.
The more intercourse
there is between AI
and modern psychology--
and also the reawakening
of depth psychology within
clinical psychiatry,
where it had been dead and
crushed out like a Freudian
cigarette butt for
more than a generation
and seems to be
gradually reawakening.
I think that's a wonderful sign.
And we're entering,
finally-- we are re-entering
an age of psychology of
the individual as opposed
to the template.
And that can only be good.
AUDIENCE: You said
a couple times
that it's not possible
for a computer system
to have an inner life
and that kind of thing.
How can you state that is-- I
hope I'm characterizing this
correctly-- but state that
it's basically impossible when
this is really all
about information.
For example, if you simulate
creativity or problem-solving,
you will have, I think, if
you're simulating it correctly,
real ideas and
real solutions that
come out of it, even if
simulating a computer enjoying
the scent of a flower would
not be really enjoying
the scent of a flower.
Like, those seem like those
are kind of different things.
And it seems like you
could have an inner life
or an inner world, even
if you do not directly
experience the physical world.
DAVID GELERNTER:
Well, it depends,
of course, what you
mean by an inner world.
And the definition is up to you.
If by inner world you
merely mean capacity
to deal with input that we would
describe as sensory input--
about the environment,
about the temperature,
about the breeze, about
things like that-- then you
have an inner world.
That's a definition most
people would reject, though.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm
thinking specifically
about the-- for example,
the example you gave earlier
about creativity and thinking
of an analogy for something
and having it be in
the back of your mind.
And you think of
something when you're not
trying to think of it.
Like, why couldn't a computer
do that if it's all just
information?
DAVID GELERNTER: I think a
computer absolutely could do it
and should do it.
I think a computer could
simulate the entire spectrum.
I wrote years ago--
one of the things that
was kicking around the
net-- that true AI won't
be achieved until we have
computers that hallucinate.
And I think this is achievable.
The entire spectrum can exist
in the sense of performance.
And I think it's very
important that it does exist.
If I care about
AI, I care about AI
being able to think creatively
as well as logically.
To do that, I want it to
be able to-- creativity's
not just a single thing.
But one important thing is
this creation of new analogies.
There are many ways to
create new analogies.
But one important method
within that variety of methods
is an emotional one.
Now, if I'm [INAUDIBLE]
and I pull out of my memory
the idea of a
cracked teacup when
I'm looking up
and seeing a bird,
I'm probably having an
emotional experience.
That is, I feel something.
It made me feel a certain way.
I can't describe it in words
because feelings in general
are indescribable.
But I might say some
sort of warm, slight,
tingling with a reminiscence
of a brown room in somewhere
or other.
I can't really describe it.
But I have a feeling.
Now, nonetheless, I could make
a computer do the same thing
while feeling nothing.
There is no reason why a
computer can't simulate
the entire spectrum and
all the nuances of emotion,
just as it's easy to do a
thought experiment in which we
live in a zombie world.
And none of us has in our
life, and we're all faking it.
Or half of us are.
It's a thought experiment which
has convinced many people,
and is convincing, I think.
And so yes, a computer can
simulate this whole spectrum.
And the importance of
the spectrum in computing
is that it can and should.
We should be able
to build a computer
that can jog up and
down the spectrum, that
can move adaptively to
different points in the spectrum
and that also drifts lower
so that it encounters
the same environment and
these same set of problems
from different standpoints as
it moves down the spectrum.
It's not a goal of
this research to say,
here's how you create a
computer with an inner life,
or, on the other hand, to say,
my goal is to prove to you that
you cannot do that.
I take it as proved
by other people.
Of course, it's
still under debate.
It's not as if there's
only one side to it.
But from my point of view, it's
proved that a digital computer
will never feel anything.
But taking that for
granted, we can still build
enormously sophisticated AI.
We can achieve a true artificial
intelligence, a true humanlike
intelligence.
But we can't unless
we see the spectrum
and reproduce it, among a lot
of other things, of course.
But one of the things
we need is the spectrum.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is, why do we
need to distinguish feelings
from other things
that you experience?
Let me give a bit of
background why I'm asking this.
In my simplistic
engineering view,
feelings must be the
result of experience,
biology, a current situation,
current state of my body,
my machine.
And with that, a
feeling is basically
the result of all
those different things
at any point in time, in
my personal understanding.
So I'm wondering, if that's
not completely crazy,
why could a computer
not also say, oh, OK.
With all the things that I
currently experience and know
and maybe-- I
don't know-- power,
input is great or
it's not great,
or whatever it is, I'm feeling
good, or I'm feeling sad,
or whatever you could feel.
DAVID GELERNTER: Excuse me.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So just to repeat, why do we
need to distinguish feelings
from other things?
DAVID GELERNTER: It certainly
is not completely crazy.
In fact, it's a natural
reaction, I think,
of nearly anybody and
everybody involved
in the sciences or medicine
or engineering at first.
And this was the
philosophical viewpoint
associated with
materialism, when
we look at the philosophy
of mind, roughly
speaking, midcentury,
mid-20th century, middle
of the last century.
And the reason why materialism
died and was replaced
by functionalism,
which is still pretty
much the current philosophical
wisdom on philosophy of mind--
the work of Hilary Putnam
and [INAUDIBLE] and others
is because so many
people on second thought,
when the physiologists
had said, you
want to know what nostalgia it?
It's these neurons firing in
the dopaminergic neo striatal
cortex while these neurons are
suppressed in the something
something something.
And the potential here is
this, and the potential there
is that.
And on second thought,
people would say, all right.
Fine.
You're telling me what causes
my feeling of nostalgia.
But where is the feeling itself?
Where is the feeling
of nostalgia?
If you're saying that there
is an equivalence in identity
between a certain voltage or
between certain set of neuron
activities and feelings,
I'll tell you you're wrong.
You're comparing
apples and oranges.
You're making the
original category error
because a feeling
is not a voltage.
A feeling has nothing
to-- a feeling
is not a matter of neurons
or a particular chemical
environment.
We know a feeling
when we experience it.
This is something that
human beings have managed
to agree among themselves.
This is the nature
of an inner life,
the nature of a subjective
reaction, as opposed--
there are a million reasons to
feel itchy because something
touches your skin or there's
some pollen suffusing
the atmosphere or
because of some entirely
physiological event.
But none of them is itchiness.
Itchiness is an
experience, is a feeling.
Now, in the final analysis,
this really is an assertion.
It's an assertion more than a
logical, provable proposition.
It's an assertion with
which functionalism started.
And functionalism succeeded
as a philosophical approach
because people have
proven unwilling to accept
the identity theory,
so-called, or the materialism.
I mean, there are
certainly materialists
in the broader sense.
But the philosophically
materialist
view that a feeling
just was certain kind
of neural activity.
The neural activity seems to
leave something critical out,
namely the feeling itself,
the qualitative feeling.
So to conclude, there's not
a proof that you're wrong.
And certainly, what
you're saying isn't crazy.
Again, as I say, it's
a natural reaction.
But it tends to
have been rejected
by those who insist that
they can clearly distinguish
a feeling on the one hand
from physiological events
on the other.
They're just different
kinds of event.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I got to believe this now.
I don't agree, but I believe it.
DAVID GELERNTER: Fair enough.
AUDIENCE: So I'm tempted to
play a 60-second version of 20
questions.
Does a chimpanzee or an
orangutan really feel?
Or are they a zombie in
your way of thinking?
DAVID GELERNTER: I
don't have the vaguest
idea in the absolute sense.
But I would be astonished
if they didn't feel simply
because the idea of relevant
similarity, which is introduced
by philosophers of
mind in, I don't know,
the '70s and the '80s-- although
is discussed by Wittgenstein
the 1940s-- says, on what
basis do we attribute feelings
to other creatures?
And the answer is
very straightforward.
We attribute feeling
to other creatures
and so forth that remind us
of ourselves insofar as they
seem humanlike.
That's the psychological
approach that humans take.
I take it, being a human being.
And insofar as a chimpanzee
and orangutan seems
very humanlike-- has a
face and arms and legs
and so forth-- I
would be astonished
if they didn't have feelings.
We have a wonderful
macaw at home,
who is less humanlike, in
a sense, than an orangutan,
but much brighter.
And why am I sure
he has feelings?
Because of the way
he expresses himself,
the articulate way he moves
around and moves his head
and talks, to a limited extent.
So this is just a
guess, obviously.
We can't-- I could be a
legitimate non-solipsist
and deny that animals
have feelings.
But I think they do.
AUDIENCE: So I understand.
I wasn't trying to go to
the solipsism direction.
I'm assuming that
you've got the charity
to attribute us
the same feelings
because you have
feelings, and we're
similar enough that
you probably think
that we have feelings, too.
And I was just wondering if--
DAVID GELERNTER: I don't
think it's charity, but--
AUDIENCE: In the
Greician form, right?
I'm just saying, if I look at
an orangutan or a chimpanzee,
to me, they are
so close to human
that the distinction
would-- I'd have
to really work very hard
to try to draw a principle
distinction.
But I then do wonder
about the inductive case.
Because then when you
go from the chimpanzee,
just go down the animal kingdom,
and where do you draw the line?
And on what principle
do you draw the line?
Where do they stop
having feelings?
Or do they have feelings
all the way down?
DAVID GELERNTER: Are you really,
are you serious that you find--
AUDIENCE: Yes, I am
absolutely serious.
DAVID GELERNTER: --it
hard to draw the line?
AUDIENCE: I have
seen chimpanzees.
And to me, they are
scarily close to humans
in a lot of ways.
And I take them very seriously.
DAVID GELERNTER:
Absolutely, they're
close to humans
in a lot of ways.
And there are a lot of reasons
to take them seriously.
They can't talk.
They have no language.
It seems to me--
AUDIENCE: So is
it just that they
can't express their feelings?
So I'm trying to understand.
You're defining
certain predicates.
You're saying this
one has feelings.
DAVID GELERNTER: Right.
AUDIENCE: That thing doesn't.
It's a zombie.
It looks like it's feeling
clever, but it doesn't really.
I'm trying to just understand
the predicate better.
How do you draw the
line between-- what's
the characteristics of
something that has feelings?
DAVID GELERNTER: Between
a zombie on the one hand
and a chimpanzee on the
other, is that the question?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm trying to
understand in the biological--
DAVID GELERNTER: I
look at the zombie.
The zombie is a completely
humanlike robot.
You know, my first guess,
does he have feelings?
Of course he does.
I have no reason
to question whether
any other human-- evidently
human being-- has feelings.
Of course I'm going to
believe he has feelings.
He may be my best friend.
I may spend 25 years
discussing my deepest problems
and feelings with him.
I only learn that he
has no feelings when
he says, by the way,
let me open my head
and show you what's inside.
And he says, you see?
I'm software.
I've got a computer here, and
I'm executing instructions.
And then I can say, well, OK.
I revert to the work of
other philosophers, which
has convinced me that
executing instructions
in the digital computer is never
sufficient to produce feelings.
So it's a conclusion
that I draw logically,
not on the basis of behavior.
Behavior all points-- physical
manifestations all point
in the other way.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
asking logically.
DAVID GELERNTER: And exactly
the same with the chimpanzee.
Everything that the
chimpanzee does makes me say,
this guy must have feelings.
Of course he has feelings.
Is he conscious?
Of course he's conscious.
Now, if there were
some way that you
could prove to me
that that was false,
then I'd accept it, if
it were a valid proof.
But I certainly-- but
I can't even concede
what such a proof would be.
And in the lack of such a proof,
I'm going to say, of course.
Of course these
creatures have feelings.
Of course they're conscious.
And I'm also going to agree
with those philosophers who
say as resemblance tails
off, my willingness
to believe that these
other creatures are
conscious in the sense that I
am or have feelings in the sense
that I am-- I'm more convinced
that a chimpanzee does
than a rabbit does, more
convinced that a rabbit does
than a turtle does, more
convinced that a turtle does
than a worm does.
This isn't an absolute
black and white thing.
This is tailing off of
probabilities, in my view,
of the world, and of
guesses about things
that I can never know.
AUDIENCE: So last question--
assume, go somewhere down
in that hierarchy.
And assume at some
point, decades from now,
neuroscience actually
works, and we actually
solve some small creature.
That is, we can
predict it accurately.
We understand how to grow it
from one cell, all of that,
maybe a worm or something.
Would that be troublesome
if you were previously
attributing feelings
to it, and then we
solved the neuroscience?
Would you then say, I was wrong?
Or would there be
something that we
could solve the neuroscience
of that you would still
admit into the things
that can have feelings?
DAVID GELERNTER: The more
we learn, the better.
And there's no reason to
think that the physiology
of subjective life
is unsolvable.
I have no reason to think that
it's an unsolvable problem.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVID GELERNTER: I just don't
think it's been solved yet.
And I don't know how
it will be solved.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Kind of similar to
the last question,
but I'm curious what you think
about the thought experiment
where with sufficiently
advanced technology,
we take a live human,
who we probably agree
is conscious and has feelings.
And one by one, we would replace
the neurons in their brain
with computers which
perfectly simulate
the behavior of the neurons.
And this can take as long--
over a long period as you want.
And so bit by bit,
the human brain
becomes a digital computer.
Do you think at some point,
that brain becomes a zombie?
Or what's happening there?
DAVID GELERNTER:
Yes, absolutely.
This is a thought experiment
associated with [INAUDIBLE].
I didn't hear the first
part of what you said,
and maybe that's exactly
what you did say.
[INAUDIBLE] has been
quoted, sort of,
as authoritative by a
lot of people, Hofstadter
and many others.
I think it's completely
unconvincing.
As a thought experiment,
first of all,
you tell me you bring somebody
in and gradually replace
all his neurons with
electronic circuits.
And then at the end
of the procedure,
you say, how are you feeling?
You have a conversation
with him the whole time,
so you keep track
of what's going on.
And when it's all over,
you say, how are things?
And he says, I feel
exactly the same as before.
This raises a
fundamental question
about thought experiments,
which-- what is illegitimate
in a thought experiment?
You know, when I do
this thought experiment,
the subject is
guaranteed to die.
It makes absolutely no sense
to say that I'm gradually
pulling out the
organic components,
pulling out the chemical
environment in which I work,
the physiochemical
environment, replacing them
by electronic parts,
and asserting that it
will make no difference.
Granted, we do
thought experiments
in order to explore
possibilities
that are difficult to
achieve in real life.
But nonetheless, not
every thought experiment
is admissible.
If I say I've done
a thought experiment
in which I'm standing
on the top of the hill
wearing gigantic bat wings.
And I jump off the cliff,
and I can see myself soaring
from Cambridge to Boston.
I can say, well, that's a
good thought experiment.
But unfortunately,
I can't accept it.
It doesn't hold up logically.
And that is the
way the [INAUDIBLE]
thought experiment strikes me.
But I think what would happen
is as you replace neurons
of your unfortunate
graduate student's brain
or whoever you've chosen
to test this out on,
what's going to happen is he's
going to lose consciousness.
And then he's going to
start feeling very strange.
I mean, I can't say exactly.
But something is
going to happen.
He's not just going
to sit there chatting
about baseball with you as
his brain is dug out piece
by piece.
I can't accept that.
So yeah, would he
become a zombie?
He would become dead.
If you really were able to
maintain the organic framework
while having replaced the
organic brain with a computer
in this incremental way--
if you were able to do that,
yeah, a zombie.
But certainly not
more than a zombie.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the great talk.
It was very interesting.
In your talk, you
seemed to be focusing
on feelings and emotions.
And a couple times,
you actually mentioned
the problem of qualia.
Once you said that
you don't believe
that executing the set of
instructions in a computer
will reproduce the feeling.
By that, you probably meant
reproduce the inner world,
the actual feeling.
Now, why stop there?
I think the same can
be applied to thinking.
Do you think that executing
a set of instructions
in a computer will actually
produce the actual thinking?
What I'm trying to say is
that the qualia applied
to the thought, to thinking.
DAVID GELERNTER:
It's a good question.
And absolutely, qualia
are always present.
I think it would be
virtually impossible to make
yourself think without being
aware of any qualia at all.
And of course, we know, in
fact, that to steer your mind,
you use impulses.
You use emotions.
You say, this direction is
more attractive or it's easier
or it's more beautiful.
This problem is more pressing.
I'll go this way.
This is more dangerous.
It scares me.
So I'll solve this problem
and ignore that one.
So emotions are
there as guide posts,
just as I'm proving a theorem in
my maximum mathematician mode,
I need memory constantly to
fetch methods and results
and remember what I
did five minutes ago.
It's not as if
memory isn't there.
But memory and emotions
don't play the vivid role--
they don't play the controlling,
vivid role that they
do when you're falling asleep,
much less when you are asleep.
So it's not that they
don't exist up spectrum.
And by the same token,
when you're dreaming,
it's not the case that
you aren't thinking at all
and you can remember nothing.
Sometimes, you can
remember nothing.
But it's not unusual to remember
some fragments of dreams.
It's not unusual to
think about what's
happening to some extent.
But we clearly
don't think about it
in the same skeptical,
critical way
we would think when we
were paying attention
and when our focus was
concentrated rather
than diffuse, towards the
bottom of the spectrum.
So yeah, I never want
to say there are qualia.
But I do want to say that qualia
play a far more important role
as incrementally,
gradually, they
come on strong and stronger
as we move down the spectrum.
AUDIENCE: So why does organic
matter produce consciousness?
If zombies were possible-- I
mean, I think ants are zombies.
And ant colonies are quite
evolutionarily successful.
Why would nature not
perfectly happily create
little troupes of
chimpanzees that are not
conscious but nevertheless
express emotion to one
another for the social
function of making
the troupe of chimpanzees happy,
or-- well, not literally happy.
They're zombies.
But making them more
successful gathering bananas
or whatever happens there.
I mean, I think you're
committing yourself
to a one-step-above science
thinking here by saying,
OK, we have the natural
world that creatures evolve,
and they produce life, and
they live and do things.
But why not just stop at ants?
If there was-- there has
to be that extra thing.
And if it's not produced
purely from nature,
purely from physics, then
what is producing it?
Why is it there?
DAVID GELERNTER: I apologize
for creating the impression
that feelings are not
produced by physics.
I don't claim that at all.
I'm taking a strictly
materialist view of this.
But there's a big
difference between saying,
certainly, this is
a natural phenomena,
and physics is all there is,
at least in this discussion.
There's a big difference
between saying that and saying,
I can explain to you
exactly how it works.
We have to recognize the
existence of unsolved problems.
As far as I'm concerned,
subjective feelings
are created and
explicable by physics.
But we don't know how.
And as far as you're saying, why
didn't evolution stop, I mean,
this is a very,
very good question.
It's a deep question, not
for me but for Darwin.
That is, if you
believe philosophers--
who are not quite
unanimous but are nearly
unanimous in
philosophy of mind--
that consciousness
accomplishes nothing,
that-- I argue in the book
that one could believe
that consciousness itself
plays a certain role
in analogy-forming, in
memory, because of what you
might call resonance effects.
It's just speculation.
Certainly the mainstream
view is that consciousness
does absolutely nothing
for you whatsoever.
And then the question
is, why should
the mechanism of
consciousness, whatever
it is-- it's some sort
of physical mechanism.
It isn't magic.
It isn't divine intervention,
as far as I'm concerned.
Why should it have evolved?
And the answer is, I don't know.
The answer is, that's a very
good question for Darwin.
And the hypothesis that
Darwinian evolution
is a perfect, proven
whole, it's just not true.
If you talk to evolutionary
and developmental biologists,
you'll find all
sorts of them who
will give you all sorts
of profound unhappinesses
they have with Darwin,
particularly about
the formation and
evolution of body plans,
the organization of creatures,
the HOX genes, so-called,
in a larger sense, as well as,
of course, the older questions
about the fossil records.
That's a good example of an
area in which we don't know.
Darwin certainly has a
better theory than anybody
else right now.
But that doesn't mean
we know he's right.
We don't know he's right.
And consciousness is a difficult
problem for standard Darwinism
and neo-Darwinism.
Good question.
I don't know how
it's going to end up.
AUDIENCE: Quick follow-up.
It'll be really short.
I mean, I think zombies
are preposterous,
that you could have this
whole thing that-- but I also
think a disembodied intelligence
running in a data center that's
fully emotionally aware
is preposterous, also.
Like, I think my viewpoint's
in between yours.
But I just find
it very difficult
to accept zombies and the
idea that we have something
that's indistinguishable
from consciousness
but not conscious.
I mean, ants act like ants.
DAVID GELERNTER:
Well, the reason
I disagree-- people
tend to disagree
sort of on experiential,
empirical grounds.
20 years ago, when I first
started working on this,
I built a program with
an adjustable focus knob.
And the idea is that when
you turn the dial down,
it would move down the spectrum.
It would start to, instead
of logically chaining
its pseudo-memories
together, it would
start doing something more
like free associating.
And eventually, when you had the
dial turned all the way down,
it would wander off and pay
no attention to you at all.
Now, this did absolutely
nothing of any value.
It was an interesting demo.
It showed me how much I didn't
know about my own theory.
Now that I figured out things
that were not clear to me then,
I'd like to go back
to the software
and continue from there.
And I don't see any
reason why I shouldn't
be able to build a
highly-accurate simulation
of the spectrum.
But by the same token,
I don't see any reason
to believe that that
simulation would
have consciousness or feelings.
So it's an open point.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID GELERNTER: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID GELERNTER: Thank you.